a
[Música]
ah
se trata de un conflicto de difícil
solución armenia reivindica el derecho a
la autodeterminación de la población de
nagorno karabaj y la respalda con su
propio ejército mientras que azerbaiyán
considera a karabaj parte de su
territorio y exige la salida de lo que
considera fuerzas de ocupación un
callejón sin salida que intenta resolver
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
convocando aquí en moscú a los ministros
de exteriores de ambas partes
azerbaiyán y armenia con el objetivo de
conseguir por lo menos un alto el fuego
que permita a ambos bandos intercambiar
los cadáveres de los soldados caídos
durante los últimos días que se cuentan
por cientos y también intercambiar
algunos prisioneros de guerra ambas
partes se acusan mutuamente de haber
iniciado esta escalada bélica en la que
están utilizando no solo artillería sino
también aviación y misiles que están
destruyendo muchas zonas civiles a ambos
lados de la línea de combate
[Música]
se empieza a llenar el camino para poner
fin a la guerra de libia los
representantes de los dos gobiernos
rivales han llegado a un nuevo acuerdo
tras las últimas reuniones que han
tenido lugar aquí en marruecos la
delegación del consejo de estado el
senado que es el senado de la parte
oeste del conflicto reconocida por la
onu y la delegación del parlamento de
tobruk la parte de este del conflicto
han llegado a un acuerdo sobre los
criterios para la futura asignación de
puestos de soberanía y este acuerdo
llega después de que se celebrará otra
reunión en egipto donde las partes
pactaron una desescalada de la violencia
cabe recordar que libia se encuentra
sumida en el caos y la guerra desde que
en 2011 la otan contribuyera a la
victoria rebelde sobre la dictadura de
gadafi con el tiempo el conflicto se
convirtió en una guerra multinacional
librará a manos de milicias locales y
ejércitos y mercenarios extranjeros
ahora casi una década después se espera
poder unificar las conversaciones de paz
con el reconocimiento de la comunidad
internacional y tratar de empezar a
poner fin a una guerra que ha costado
miles de vidas y que ha obligado a
millones de personas a desplazarse o
refugiarse en otros países
[Música]
cuando estamos a menos de seis meses de
cumplirse diez años de la guerra en
silla la situación del hambre y la
pobreza se encuentra en su momento más
crítico según la organización mundial de
los alimentos 9.3 millones de sirios se
encuentran en inseguridad alimentaria y
2.2 más podrían estarlo en los próximos
meses como consecuencia de muchas
razones una de ellas es la crisis
económica por la que atraviesa el país
agudizada por las sanciones impuestas al
gobierno la crisis económica al líbano
que es un pulmón para la economía local
y el kobe 19 esto hace que un mercado
por ejemplo valga 23 veces más que
costaba antes de la guerra pero no
solamente es una cuestión económica el
hambre y la pobreza han sido utilizadas
como arma de guerra no solamente por el
gobierno sino también por los grupos
rebeldes y actualmente incluso para
muchas organizaciones internacionales es
muy complicado y hay que negociar mucho
antes de poder entrar estos alimentos y
darlos a las poblaciones más vulnerables
[Música]